Pokemon scarlet and violets are out now
and the reception to both highly
anticipated titles has been mixed to say
the least multiple reviews including our
own Gamespot mentioned that while the
open world is an excellent step forward
for the franchise the games are held
back by technical issues such as pop-in
frame rate drops and muddy textures as
such the current score at Gamespot
sister site Metacritic sits at a 77
which is the lowest score for a new
Mainline Pokemon game ever before these
entries no new generation of Pokemon has
scored below an 80 before I should note
that neither Pokemon red blue or gold
silver have ratings on the site but
their remakes fire red leaf green and
heart gold soul silver are also rated
highly which of course they are because
those are some of the greatest games of
all time despite the mixed reception to
the new games it seems to not have had
any effect on sale as college and
violets are the most pre-ordered Pokemon
games in the series history the Pokemon
company's Chief Operating Officer takato
itsunomiya announced the news at a
launch event for the pair of Pokemon
games though didn't specify how many
pre-orders the games had received he did
note that 440 million units of Pokemon
related games have been sold since the
launch of the very first titles in Japan
Pokemon red and green online the
community seems to be completely divided
on the issue half of the fandom wants
game freak and the Pokemon company to
make improvements and the other half
claims that any technical issues the
games have do not affect their enjoyment
of them personally I find it a little
immersion breaking when characters in an
open world may feat in front of you move
at half the frame rate but maybe that's
just me if you are picking up either of
the new games make sure to grab your
free rare Pikachu once you unlock the
Poke portal in the game which requires
you to start the treasure hunt activity
early on you'll be able to access
mystery gifts like in previous entries
in the series select get via internet
and the Pikachu will be awarded to you
what makes this Pikachu worth obtaining
besides the adorability factor this
particular electric rat knows the move
fly which Pikachu are usually incapable
of learning usually reserved for flying
type Pokemon fly is a useful two-ton
attack that can demolish fighting and
grass type Pokemon on the field adding
some extra utility to this particular
Pikachu this Pikachu will also change
its typing from Electric to Flying when
it is terasterized the new power up
mechanic in the game make sure to head
to gamespot.com for a ton and I do mean
a ton more content around Pokemon
scarlet and violet if you're still in
too deep with Call Of Duty Modern
Warfare 2 and Warzone 2 to care about
pocket monsters and you also to have
Xfinity Internet I hope you haven't paid
for your battle pass yet as you can pick
it up for free members can head to their
rewards and Deals page in their account
and the code should be waiting according
to popular Twitter user that focuses on
all things Call of Duty Charlie Intel as
a reminder the battle pass does away
with the linear nature of previous ones
and instead offers a multi-sector map
players use battle tokens to unlock
items within a certain sector claiming
all items in a sector unlocks the next
one what do you think about the
performance issues in Pokemon Scarlets
and violet let us know in the comments
and we'll see you next time for more
Gamespot news